thank you thank you for inviting me on
the show i appreciate it i got a
microphone in everything
you got a question yeah so the question
is is that i recently got on t
and uh it's a brand new thing for me so
went to the doctor
uh it's been two months okay so i
already knew
very neat yeah doctor tried to throw me
onto ssris
went through that whole thing uh had to
go get multiple tests to prove i mean
i'm older by the way me 35. okay so
pretty young though
yeah still pretty young but i went
through a crazy divorce uh
absolute nightmare i'm you know i'm a
whole show for you
on its own but uh basically got 50
custody of my kid so that's what matters
right
and got my job to go around it but the
whole point was that went to the doctor
getting back on subject and he wanted me
to get onto ssris
he made me go and get multiple checks to
make sure that my levels were
good enough now there's conflicting
information
being from victoria or canada there's
totally different than what's going on
in the u.s
so he kept on using terms like eight on
my test results
like you're at eight which is low do you
know directly what that
this is very confusing
the measurement scale
that they use in canada is different
than the us so we have
uh like in the us they use something
uh measured as nanograms per deciliter
which i was quoting which is what most
people would be familiar with because
way more of my views come from there but
to give you an example like
bioavailable testosterone is what's
available in your blood
and the range on my labs here is 3.6 on
the low end
to 11.2 on the high end okay so if
you're saying
eight is low he's probably referring to
not the bioavailable but the um
just a testosterone level which i don't
even have on this because because my guy
doesn't test it because he's smart
enough to know not to test
um just the levels let me see if it was
in one of the early ones
i'll tell you what the range was there
but um nine on one
eight on the other and he said to get me
on it which is great
that they were saying was high and low
uh he was saying
high was above 11 and he was saying low
is anything below nine
okay so you're below the range then
which would qualify you now
was it a family doctor or was it a
clinic yeah a family doctor
family doctor okay so they scripted you
testosterone
yeah he scripted me started me off at
200 uh every two weeks
which like you said felt like a rock
star for three days until you hit a
brick wall and you wonder why you feel
like right
yeah um last week i decided just to
start doing my own injections he made me
go into the office
for the first four ejections yeah and
while doing that the last time he
actually
almost broke off the needle in my butt
which is
he literally stabbed me and then he like
screamed like he was in a panic and what
happened was he didn't twist on the end
of the needle properly
so it popped and i got a needle sticking
on my butt blood's all over the place
and he's covered in testosterone
so i was like all right i need to change
this up and i did a bit of research and
i've been a long time follower of your
content so i found some breadcrumbs and
put it together
but i'm changing myself 200 per week so
is that the proper range we should be
looking at or 125 or
i'm trying to get this all dialed in it
it all depends on
how you feel and what your labs say okay
so
you could be a hyper responder at 100
milligrams per week and
and end up with like like bodybuilder
sort of like levels in your blood
you may not be and you might need 150
you might need 200
to get to levels that make you feel
healthy so
you have to do it on those two things so
it's so it's administer
test manage administer test manage right
and then you make adjustments as you go
but um are you on an ai
no no i'm not at all that's just
straight so and
how what i would do you're doing the
administration
is what i was talking about earlier is
backfill one of the big boys
okay or sorry philip you know one of the
big boys and then you backfill an
insulin
syringe okay okay uh and if you're in
canada there's a company called
uh surgego s-u-r-g-o.com
you can order online from them you know
syringes are super cheap
you get them in bulk and you just stack
them i mean you know because you're
going to be using for a long time
so you know you just store the
testosterone here and then you just
you know drop about 10 iu in every other
day
are you on hcg uh no that was the other
thing i was going to ask about when you
mentioned that
okay so you know if you do it every
other day like just pin yourself
uh ventral glute glute you can do
shoulder
you can do pack if you have you know
like enough um meat there
there's different areas these huge
needles like literally i started off
with the giant ones and they stabbed me
in my thigh
i almost just exactly something that i
started with too it's the worst
and yeah and that's why it gets a bad
rap from some people and some guys quit
or you see these morons that are like
you know you're a loser if you're on
trt no like you have to understand how
to manage these things so that you get
the results that you want and you can't
like
it's like the red pill like you can't
rely on what society and media and
government and school
and religion has taught you because
clearly that doesn't work
i'm telling you man you have to apply
this lens to different areas of your
life
including your own health and you can't
like
as nice it is you know to see the
thing around their neck and the
white coat with little badge on it
saying that they're a doctor most of
them don't know what the hell they're
doing when it comes to trt
yeah he told me that it should be two
weeks because you have to wait for the
system to kick back in or it's gonna
have negative
con like it's i would say for that right
i would say
micro like if your weekly dose is 100
milligrams i would say micro dose that
into an every other day dose back
filling an insulin you know
syringe and for me my favorite spot to
inject is the ventral glute and you can
find videos on
on how to do that it's really easy to
get to it doesn't hurt there's no nerve
endings there there's no big veins in
that area
it's it's super convenient um so
that's what i would be doing what was
your question with hcg
uh just more about it um this is
honestly the first time hearing about it
and so just what is it and how do i
implement it in but you said every other
right so you just alternate
yeah so i do t one day hcg and i just
keep alternating so
okay that's my protocol but um
some some guys will do just fine on
testosterone so i would just stick with
the testosterone for now
see how you feel make sure you know your
uh
your cognitive function is great you
know you can focus you're productive
uh your sexual function is great i'm
more productive at work i'm down 36
pounds over three months
you know working out you know i got
bored so i put a squat rack and weight
since just every single day
you know changing my life you know yeah
right your butt doing the work
so to the point of the hcg only add it
if you feel like you need it like if
your
balls hurt too much you know because the
atrophy's too much or if you're not
feeling the focus or if your sexual
functions you know decline some guys
will need
hcg for me i feel better on hcg with
testosterone
i know there's some guys in the us that
are having a hard time getting hcg
because i think that clinics are
either not able to get it or there's
something with uh
i don't know substance bands or whatever
they've got they've got
substitutes for hcg if you're a
us citizen and you're having a hard time
get it so ask ask
your clinic about that or do some
research for it but if you're canadian
again you know if if it's not solving
all the symptoms then consider adding it
and
and seeing how you feel but if you don't
need it then don't use it yeah my
benefits cover it so i mean i'm paying
six dollars for a bottle does it it's
like
you know why add it to the protocol
if you don't need it like one of the
other benefits to hcg which is like one
of the main pitches is if you're on that
then you'll maintain your fertility
right like you'll have a good sperm
count so that's one of the other
benefits to hcg is if you want to have
kids
i've already had a kid i'm good yeah
like i don't want to have any more kids
but i
but i'm using it because i feel better
on it right because
clearly my receptors require it i feel
better on it everything performs better
so that's why i continue to use it
that being said there's some
misinformation out there which i should
mention which i didn't touch on
there's some guys which will say well if
you just go on testosterone
then you become infertile which means
you can just
bust nuts everywhere right you know sort
of thing you're not going to knock
anybody up
not true there's a lot of guys that i
know that
knocked up their girlfriend or their
wife while on testosterone thinking that
they were sterile when they're not
right everybody
yeah yeah absolutely you good bro
i'm good thanks for all that all right
thanks for chiming in man take care
you